smaller media you know you're not gonna
like do level 57. Chelsea Handler
referencing x 50 Cent In a very specific
way I'm definitely open to all sorts of
possibilities on that front yeah the
comedian not so subtly mentions her old
flame during a comedy bit while
attempting to destigmatize a certain
sexual activity
is a homosexual men anymore
and you pick the right candidate right
smaller media you know you're not gonna
like do level 50 Cent
and now 50s reacting to those not safe
for work comments it's a little more
subtle didn't have you know different
words to use he shared the clip on
Instagram calling Chelsea so crazy but
hands down the funniest I'm like yo like
did that just happened Chelsea and 50
dated briefly over a decade ago both
confirmed the fling was short-lived
which reportedly was due to unresolved
feelings between the rapper and his ex R
B singer Sierra despite 50 and Chelsea's
romance coming to an end the two clearly
remain cordial with Chelsea gushing over
him publicly on several occasions over
the years he's a great guy yeah people
think he's you know his Persona that's
something I thought he was his Persona
he's completely antithetical to who he
is in real life yes it's a sweetheart
he's like and he's like so cute and you
just want to like you know hang from his
neck what would you call him
I know it's not like you could be in bed
and be like 50.
so we spoke the other night and I said
you know jokingly like I'm ready to get
back together or possibly go for another
spin I know this is a Morning Show so I
won't go too deep into that and he was
like hey were you serious about what you
wrote about us getting back together and
I was like yeah totally I'm open to
anything buddy so who knows maybe I'll
get back together with 50. he actually
got a kick out of me he gets my humor
and he likes it and finds it attractive
and not like a turn off
as of now Chelsea's enjoying the single
life after her split from fellow
comedian and actor Joe Coy last year the
relationship didn't work out we both
went our separate ways and that's okay
too you know I had kind of lost my faith
in men and you know I then I got into a
relationship and I that that Faith was
renewed and it made me open-minded and
open-hearted and I remain that way and
so I'm grateful for that time together
we all have a tendency to feel like you
know we're stronger with someone next to
us and that can be true but you can also
have the strength on your own and it's
really important for all young people
growing up whether you're a female male
or you know don't identify as either
it's important to know your own strength
and your own power we all have this huge
reservoir of strength within us you know
and you gotta tap into that at certain
times in your life and shine and you can
Shine by yourself
[Music]